monsieur kingsley
c'est merveilleux d'avoir cette opportunité
de vous parler j'ai
attendu de nombreuses années pour me retrouver face à face
avec le vrai ben kingsley
je voudrais vous demander quelle est la
question
que les journalistes vous posent le plus
[Applaudissements]
ils m'ont posé  quelle est la différence
entre jouer au cinéma
et jouer au théâtre et chaque fois que
je leur donne une réponse différente, j'ai donc
confondu les gens
partout dans le monde comment vous sentez-vous quand les
gens vous parlent de
je me sens très heureux si je marchais  dans
la rue
[musique]
avec un ami et mon ami a dit regarde
il y a l'acteur qui a joué le mahatma
gandhi je serais un
homme très malheureux ton vrai nom est beau
c'est krishna qui est le dieu indien de l'
amour et du banji qui est un très noble
et ancien nom indien pourquoi avez-vous changé
je pense que c'est probablement une bonne idée pour un
acteur comme moi
d'avoir un nom reconnaissable
facile à retenir mais plus neutre vous avez
refusé de jouer anwar sadat
est-ce parce que vous êtes fe  d up with
peace heroes
euh c'était la première offre substantielle
que j'ai reçue après avoir remporté l'oscar
et j'ai pensé que ce serait très stupide de
ma part d'
accepter la première offre qui s'est présentée et
c'est
en fait comme ça que ça s'est passé et ne  t
vous pensez qu'il aurait été idiot d'
accepter la première offre,
cela signifie que je n'aurais pas fait de
trahison, ce qui était un
film merveilleux, je n'aurais pas fait
toutes sortes de travaux et mon agent, nous
parlions de cela l'autre  jour
et mon agent à Londres a dit que vous aviez pris une
décision très sage le personnage que vous
jouez dans l'île de pascalis est un homme déchiré
entre
l'occident et l'orient est-ce un
problème que vous avez
souffert de vous-même eh bien cela pourrait être
mon problème
si je  n'étais pas un acteur c'est-à-dire
si je n'étais pas capable d'exprimer ce qui est
essentiellement moi qui est un merveilleux
mélange
de toutes sortes de choses que nous sommes tous mais
particulièrement moi-même et des gens comme moi
je pense que si je n'étais pas un acteur je pense
peut-être  je trouverais la vie abandonnée  e difficile
parce que
où pourrais-je m'exprimer comment pourrais-je
m'exprimer
je pense que si je n'étais pas un acteur je serais
probablement
créatif d'une certaine manière peut-être un écrivain
peut-être un peintre
mais je pense que si je ne pouvais pas m'exprimer je
pense que ce serait  un problème sérieux
peut-être que je serais un peu fou mais j'ai beaucoup de
chance en ce sens que je suis un acteur
si nous nous étions rencontrés dans un club comme celui-ci
qu'est-ce que tu m'aurais dit qui me pousserait
à voir ton prochain merveilleux
film incertain  que c'était un très bon rapport qualité
prix
est otello votre personnage ultime je
pense que mon personnage ultime sur scène est
probablement hamlet
mais othello était le dernier personnage que j'ai
joué sur scène
rôle cruel et impitoyable très exigeant
pour un acteur tout acteur qui joue othello
doit être prévenu
que cela lui causera beaucoup de
douleur émotionnellement
et physiquement c'est très très difficile
il y a beaucoup de rumeurs qui circulent à
propos de votre prochain personnage historique de
quoi voudriez-vous qu'il soit
[Musique]